la passante du sans-souci c'est le titre
d'un film qui vient de sortir dans les
salles de cinéma le 60e film de romy
schneider qui traverse ainsi à ses
dépends 50 ans d'histoire de france
c'est en tout cas la trame du film
dominé par l'interprétation de romy
schneider
le portrait de l'actrice et du film mis
en scène par jacques rouffio france
proche 1933 une femme qui perd amour et
fortune 1982 une femme frappée en plein
bonheur
ces deux femmes sont joués par romy
schneider dans un film qu'elle a demandé
à jacques rouffio de réaliser la
passante de sans souci
c'est le vivre des tesselles que j'ai lu
il ya très très longtemps et c'est une
de ces histoires que n'oublie pas mais
qu'on met dans un tiroir ou faire un
autre film
mais ça n'a jamais vraiment quitté
qu'est ce qu'elle va sortir le livre on
et tiroirs je peux pas comment
l'expliquer c'est des choses qui
arrivent comme l'avalanche comme comme
un cri ce film là et pour moi manière
d'avancer dans l'abysse avancer c'est
avoir fait un film engagé politiquement
sur le nazisme ou hier et le racisme
aujourd'hui ce qui est issu de des
prémices du nazisme 933 et qui s'est
poursuivie jusqu'à année 145 avec la
guerre que l'on sait il ya toujours des
ramifications de racisme toute façon et
il se trouve que selon les époques
peut-être un petit peu plus en ce moment
qu'il ya dix ans non je ne sais pas mais
ça existe et même si notre histoire est
écrite avant la rue copernic avons des
choses comme ça curieusement l'histoire
hélas nous rattrape toujours donc raison
plus pour faire des films comme ça je
crois
souvenez vous une addition des monstres
mais ça ça vous avez couché avec un as
atteint tout pendant notre tournage j'ai
reçu des coups de téléphone et des
lettres des gens totalement
à nos mines des gens qui ne
nous rien à voir avec notre métier qui
ont su un tout petit peu c'est que cesse
le thème le film que jacques rouffio
fait était en train de tourner et
c'était très encourageant les falaises
michel seraient libérés nous sommes bien
conscients de dire des gens qui vont pas
aimer du tout mais est-ce que c'est
tellement important se ne pas perdre et
je n'a pas peur d'être blâmé elle qui
malgré sa carrière éclatante a peur de
tout le trac et il est toujours là la
peur qu'on se plante la peur que comme
on fait mal son travail la peur que le
glamour
la première star européenne débute à
chaque film mais à la fin des 60e en
plein éclat et en pleine gloire elle
pense déjà parfois au départ je crois je
vais m'arrêter
on a l'âge ou le moment juste quand je
décide je ne voudrais pas faire jusqu'à
80 ans le seul hic ce métier que j'aime
beaucoup mais je m'en voudrais être une
mémé un jour à la campagne avec mes
fruits des arbres et ma fille et vivre
oh
oui